your house the reach I mean the
chameleons were attacking I got this
[Music]
she's dead torque he's dead torque yeah
Wow
we're losing everyone it's a good thing
they were already dead so who's next you
were me this is all gonna kill me for
this get is me where's wally mookie
tired of the show already well let's see
what else is on you're not giving up are
you
I would not have picked you as my beast
boy if I thought you were a quitter
what you talking about monkey you didn't
pick me
I got a Martian blood transfusion
Martian blood okay sure that helped but
face the kid you were chosen by the
magical mystical monkey god wha why do
you think you can only change into
animals and do the words conservation of
mass mean anything to you at all might
even be my magic that intervened and
messed up those goggles to keep you from
being brainwashed for good noted face it
your beast boy because I made you beast
boy I just needed a little help from
again from you I made your beast boy
though but you made yourself a hero
so tell me has that really changed Lily
wait a minute wait a minute if you're
the monkey God why do you sound like
Wally West hey don't blame me your mind
chose this voice my mind so are you real
or is this all in my head no no kid why
not ask her
[Music]
nah that's not my mom that's my
beautiful system again I'm ready to get
back to reality now ready to get back to
the life I was so worried I'm crash
feeling more Astor than I have for a
while actually hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my video all
about Wally West and why he is totally
coming back on the TV show they've been
foreshadowing at all season this is just
like the biggest scene that they've had
with him because it's literally him on
screen via this hallucination that Beast
Boy is having so I'll explain what's
going on with all this stuff too but you
probably detected all the Wally West's
Easter eggs that they've included this
season we're doing a new round of the DC
Universe giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Wally West moment on the video
so a couple important things the
showrunner actually just tweeted
something out a little while ago that
kind of confirmed my theory that I'll
talk about in a second but basically
just taking you through this
hallucination the reason why he's having
this is because he puts those granny
goodness VR goggles on and they start to
mind-control him so that he'll go to one
of the metahuman depots and the light
can induct him into Darkseid's army and
he'll just become a pawn like you've
seen all the other controlled metahumans
that they've been trying to save this
season so a couple of his mental defense
mechanisms kick in his brain tries to
save itself with a little help from The
Monkey God which I'll explain in a
second but all manifesting through the
guise of Wally West why are you speaking
with Wally West's voice don't look at me
this is all you kid so what you're
seeing is is beast boy's backstory going
all the way back to his origin like they
use funny hallucinations in the hello
Megan TV show and his weird father from
the Doom Patrol to explain what's been
happening to him this whole time and his
story from seasons 1 & 2 so it's sort of
like this really trippy elaborate acid
trip recap which is actually really cool
and I thought the Teen Titans go Doom
Patrol go was actually pretty funny too
that was all about explaining how he
wound up on this weird Star Trek parody
TV show because they all keep speaking
with that funny William Shatner voice
he's dead ooh he's dead too oh I guess
I'm next to Young Justice
is actually doing a version of the comic
book Beast Boy origin story with a
couple of changes like Miss Martian
gives them the blood transfusion but
then the monkey God gives him a little
more context for why his powers work the
way they do
oh I'm the real reason why this is
happening why do you think you can only
change into animals in the original
version of his origin story what
happened is is that after his parents
died he was just given to a
court-appointed guardian who started
embezzling funds from his family's
fortune then eventually tried to kill
him so that he could take all the money
the Doom Patrol saved him and that's
when Beast Boy became part of the Doom
Patrol then he went on to become part of
the Teen Titans so in the Young Justice
version of this when his original
parents died on the show his guardian
became Rita Farr of the Doom Patrol
they actually have the Doom Patrol
live-action TV show that's happening
right now - so this woman became his
guardian
because she was a former co-star with
his real-life mom on the hello Megan TV
show when they were younger so she had
always been his godmother she just took
him in when they died but she was also
married to this douchebag here and he
claimed those weird parental rights and
started to exploit him after the Doom
Patrol died mysteriously on a mission so
that's why this Doom Patrol Teen Titans
ghost song just keeps saying let's die
yay let's die like they just do a really
funny job of explaining what happened to
them and why he wound up in this
situation
so this all becomes a really big call to
action for him he rejects the life comes
back to consciousness and now he's gonna
join the Young Justice team so which is
Young Justice continuing to adapt his
comic book story except instead of
joining the Teen Titans he's joining the
Young Justice team but like right now we
have cyborg on Young Justice so they do
kind of have an original Teen Titans
team that's slowly forming within the
Young Justice team we even have Tara now
because they're doing a story inspired
by Teen Titans the Judas contract so
Young Justice is doing all these really
big comic book stories but most of you
can probably spot some of those subtle
changes that they have which is where we
get to the return of Wally West now kind
of confirmed by the showrunner he didn't
say that he's coming back
he just provided a critical detail for a
very seminal comic book story from the
flash comics about how a speedster comes
back seemingly from death so this all
started to seem very familiar like
there's a reason why they've been
cluding all these Wally West Easter eggs
they even show the scene where he died
there's a reason why they included that
scene in particular not just to make you
cry like that was a reason to but also
so that you would pay attention to what
happened to wall-e when they eventually
bring him back so that it all makes
sense I think this moment is like the
seventh or eighth time that they've
either referenced him or shown images of
him or actually had him in a scene so
since the season started no one has
mentioned anything about researching
what happened to him they all just
assumed that he's dead for all we know
but the flash Barry Allen and even Bart
Allen have not been featured that much
in episode so far they haven't done a
lot of speedster heavy arcs so my theory
partially confirmed because of the
showrunners tweet here is that Wally
West was turned into pure Speed Force
energy in the accident that seemingly
killed him during the season two finale
so the tweet is just like a random fan
saying yeah the showrunner said that
there is no Speed Force in the Young
Justice TV show in the showrunner is
saying no that is not what I said
effectively telling you that there's
probably Speed Force we just haven't
explained it yet like we're waiting to
do that in a story arc so remember how I
said the show is doing a version of
beast boys origin where he goes from the
Doom Patrol to the Teen Titans
the Young Justice version he was cared
for by the Doom Patrol now he's joining
the Young Justice team so just a couple
small changes they changed some of the
characters that were involved in that
story well it seems like now what Young
Justice is also doing is an origin story
for the Speed Force itself but how are
they doing that look at the clues from
seasons 1 & 2 so first all the
speedsters on the show during seasons 1
& 2 just zip around blurring across
frame really fast
there's no Speed Force lightning
crackling all around them because none
of them have discovered it yet even
Barry Allen who's been the flash for a
long time as part of the Justice League
in the comics the Speed Force was
created as a concept for the first time
in the 90s by someone called Mark Waid
during the wait for it wally west era of
the comics when he was the main version
of the flash Bart Allen was also a big
character during that run so Barry Allen
had seemingly wait for it this will seem
very familiar died during crisis on
Infinite Earths trying to destroy the
anti monitors weapon just like Wally
West seemingly died trying to destroy
the lights weapon you see this panel
here from crisis he sort of vaporizes
like he's turning into nothingness like
oh my god that's kind of what happened
to Wally West on the TV show so
eventually it sounds like what they're
doing is his young justices version of
the flash rebirth comic book story and
this time it's going to be Wally West
who seemingly comes back from the Speed
Force but they might be saving that for
the end of the second half of the season
or even season 4 it feels like a really
big moment for them to go out on like
this big crisis something goes really
crazy and all of a sudden boom Wally
West just appears out of the Speed Force
seemingly without explanation like how
did he come back what's going on and why
is he super powerful now because for the
longest time Wally West the ginger Wally
West was the fastest version of the
flash because he had the most direct
connection to the Speed Force and they
sort of introduced all these really
crazy concepts about how the Speed Force
works and when speedsters died their
bodies turned back into pure Speed Force
energy so then bringing Wally West back
in a story arc would be the combination
of a couple different stories but mainly
the flash rebirth and the Mark Waid era
when Wally West learned what the Speed
Force was so here's my big question for
you guys let me know in the comments
when do you think that they're going to
bring wally west back at the end of the
second half of the season or do you
think that they're gonna wait to season
four they haven't said anything about
being renewed for season four yet but I
think what they're gonna do is they'll
say something about that during the
second block of episodes this summer the
preist are talking about that more
especially going into comic-con but what
will happen is is this Super Bowl
weekend there'll be a bunch of Super
Bowl trailers there's supposed to be an
Avengers end game trailer there's
already been a couple so far so click
here to watch that new Captain Marvel
Super Bowl trailer and click here for
all my Young Justice season 3 videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]